there are federal judges that are
consistently trading in the equities of
the companies that are in front of them
and so how can you
this is robert kaplan president of the
dallas federal reserve bank
basically the dallas branch of america's
money printer one of the federal reserve
bank's main purposes is to supervise and
regulate financial institutions and
activities meaning fed officials have a
lot of inside information on things that
affect companies on the stock markets so
it would make sense that the people
working here shouldn't be able to use
their insider knowledge to trade stocks
right well yeah but while the fed was
desperately trying to figure out how to
handle the pandemic robert kaplan made
multiple stock trades of over a million
dollars in companies like delta airlines
apple and ocidental petroleum the
results delta airlines got a bailout of
over 5 billion in 2020 the same year
kaplan bought into the airline stock
while at the same time the fed was also
buying apple bonds to keep the company
out of debts and robert kaplan's
punishment for insider trading he
stepped down in october 2021 apparently
he didn't want to risk becoming a
distraction to the federal reserve's
execution of its monetary policy anyone
else committing insider trading would
have gotten up to 20 years in prison and
a fine of up to 5 million
robert kaplan he received an early
retirements but robert kaplan wasn't the
only one there's also new york-based
federal judge edgardo ramos he owned
exxon mobil stock while also presiding
over a pollution case involving exxon
mobil oil his verdicts the insurance
company had to pay exxon 25 million
dollars plus 8 million dollars interest
when asked why he didn't excuse himself
over the conflict of interest he said it
was because it was exxon mobil oil not
regular exxon mobil then there's federal
reserve vice chairman richard clarida he
took millions of his own money out of
bond funds and put them into stocks in
february 2020 just as the feds started
slashing interest rates on repayments
which would typically increase stocks
and then there's federal judge timothy
baden who heard 11 lawsuits involving
the bank jp morgan in just one year what
no one else knew at the time was that he
also owned shares in jp morgan at the
time of the lawsuits conveniently most
of the suits heard by judge timothy came
out in favor of the bank when asked why
he never reported it he said his
investment was managed by a broker and
he had nothing to do with it and the
great thing about all this is that it
was all legal federal judges deciding
over huge cases involving companies like
apple facebook or amazon cases that
could move the markets could also trade
knowing those decisions federal reserve
officials with the power to set interest
rates and offer bailouts that again move
markets are trading stocks in the same
companies they're supposed to oversee
and if you think it's just a few people
here and there you are sorely mistaken
forget wall street this is the real
insider training that slept right
underneath your nose
[Music]
[Music]
september 28 2021 the wall street
journal releases a shocking report that
131 federal judges heard cases where
they had financial interest in between
2010 and 2018 and suddenly it opened the
floodgates
685 cases heard over eight years and
two-thirds of those cases they ruled in
the favor of the judge's financial
interests the amount of research the
article must have took is mind-blowing
unlike politicians federal judges don't
need to disclose their financial records
they can't be found online and
requesting them means telling the judge
you're looking into their finances it's
one of the reasons no one did it before
what lawyer is going to put their name
on a financial report request when they
may need to argue a case in front of
that same judge in the future 131 judges
knowingly or unknowingly traded stocks
on the companies involved in their cases
but it wasn't the only shocker because
once the wall street journal released
their reports people started to notice
other federal employees doing the same
thing less than a month after the report
was released a request was put in for an
investigation into federal reserve
officials doing the same thing
turns out more than three high-level
people at america's money printer made
suspicious traits during the time the
fed was responding to the pandemic those
officials resigned and had to sell their
stocks no prison time no fine just a
slap on the wrist and the federal judges
well they had more wiggle room to
explain their conflicts away and here's
how you can do it yourself
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
step number one become a judge step
number two specialize in court cases
dealing with public companies these are
the cases that matter where your
decisions have the power to move stock
prices and if the company is big enough
your decision can move markets step
number three offshore your insider
trading once you know what direction the
case is headed in what direction you're
going to rule in then it's time to
offshore your insider trading your goal
is to create a wall between you and your
trades and there are two ways you can do
that one way is having your investments
managed by your brokers another way is
to do what the politicians do and have
your family members do the trading for
you that way in both cases if you ever
got caught you can just throw your hands
up in the air and say i didn't do those
trades they did i didn't tell them
anything
when you and i both know the truth
[Music]
now you may be wondering how is any of
this possible how is it legal for judges
and officials to trace stocks in the
companies they oversee well technically
it's not in the case of federal judges
there are very specific guidelines for
what to do in a case where there's a
conflict of interest the most important
thing is that you recuse yourself from
the case this means they excuse
themselves from that case and hand it
over to another judge courts have
conflict screening software that stands
for possible conflicts of interest
between the judge and their case if
anything pops up they have to recuse
themselves the only problem is this
system has a lot of holes in it like the
case with judge edgardo ramos the
conflict screening software didn't
recognize that exxon mobil and exxon
mobil oil are the same entity because it
only looks for exact matches
there's also the issue of using brokers
to manage their investments which is
what a lot of judges do in these cases
there's a lot of possible deniability
how was my broker supposed to know that
i was ruling on a case involving
facebook that kind of thing all of this
makes it very easy for judges to
overlook the fact that they're involved
in a massive conflict of interest and
when they get caught they just say they
never knew and they're really sorry the
same goes for federal reserve officials
they have such wide reaching influence
that it's like giving politicians the
keys to the ballot boxes and assuming
they won't be meddling in the election
but back to the original question how is
any of this actually possible it's
because of a very simple rule any
federal judge or official should not
engage in traits or behavior that even
just appear improper they're supposed to
behave in ways that make sure the public
trust them and that leaves a lot up to
interpretation with the rules very
subject to interpretation the judges and
officials were free to do whatever they
want but hopefully that's all about the
change
new legislation is on the table to make
insider training for judges and fed
officials illegal the newly proposed
laws would make it so that federal
judges will have to disclose their
traits online within 45 days of making
them basically the exact same world
congress members follow but at least
here the judges aren't the ones writing
their own rules like it is for
politicians in their insider trading
[Applause]
what's up guys it is currently 4am here
a little shorter of a video than usual
but it was still an important topic that
i want to cover if you're new here
subscribe for the number one channel for
documentaries on money power and crime
we have an amazing documentary coming
out on our good friend efrey jeffstein
that is obviously way too controversial
to post publicly so if you want to watch
it click that join button below and it
should be up within a few days of this
video going live there's a refund policy
so if you join it you don't think it's
worth it you can email me and i will
personally refund you the money so
pretty much risk-free but that's going
to wrap it up stay dangerous out there
and i'll see you guys in the next one
[Music]
you